mathieu plestan journalistes qui se
trouve à jeu longue en australie mathieu
plestan bonjour merci d'être en irak sur
rt france alors l'état du victoria
connaît sa pire période depuis le début
de la pandémie
comment le gouvernement australien fait
face à cette situation alors melbourne
glissé dernières heures de liberté c'est
ce soir à minuit heure locale que la
seconde ville du pays ainsi que sa
proche banlieue où on vivre cette
seconde phase de confinement qui a été
mise en place très rapidement dans la
semaine par le premier ministre de
l'état du victoria daniel andrews
l'interdiction stricte donc comme vous
l'avez dit de se déplacer de sortir de
chez soi
l'état du victoria est désormais coupée
de l'ensemble du pays les frontières
entre ces états voisins sont également
fermés l'australie méridionale l'état
voisin mais également le la nouvelle
galles du sud dont la plus grande ville
et sydney qui est fermé depuis mercredi
depuis mardi soir à minuit
alors parlons de quelques donc c'est un
fait rare ici parce que la dernière
phase de frontières ont été fermées
elle remonte à 1919 et la grippe
espagnole
si les frontières sont fermées c'est
également le cas laisser les frontières
entre les différents pays où les
différences d'état intérieur s'enfermer
c'est également le cas avec les
frontières extérieures le gouvernement a
mis en place très rapidement également l
interdiction de tous les vols
internationaux seuls les résidents
locaux qui sont qui se trouvent à
l'étranger peuvent rester à peuvent
rentrer en australie vendredi une
réunion aura lieu avec les différents
décideurs pour vraiment a décidé d'une
réduction des arrivées des vols
internationaux
c'est une mesure vraiment protectrice de
la part de l'australie dont les cas de
coronavirus dépasse et son hôte dépasse
vraiment la hausse sont vraiment à la
hausse depuis
depuis ces dernières semaines cette
nouvelle phase de confinement va
également affecter de nombreux commerces
restaurant mercredi ce mercredi de
nombreuses personnes se sont ruées vers
les restaurants pourra profiter des
derniers derniers instants avant un
retour au confinement nombreux
restaurateurs estiment que ce second
confinement va leur porter préjudice 85
% estiment 85 % de perte de chiffre
d'affaires sont estimés par à part les
restaurateurs le gouvernement pour ça
mais va continuer leur venir en aide
grâce à une aide d'état mise en place au
début de la pandémie de john key peur
qui va leur père mais qui va leur
permettre une aide financière mais
beaucoup de restaurateurs créée pourra
pour leur futur tolérance zéro donc de
la part du milieu de canberra pour cette
seconde phase de confinement à melbourne
environ 3000 personnes qui vivent dans
des immeubles d'habitation ont reçu
l'ordre de rester enfermés chez eux
après à l'apparition d'un foyer dans une
tour environ 75 personnes ont contracté
le virus
donc cette mesure est la plus stricte
mesure jamais et mis en place en
australie depuis le début de la pandémie
par canberra
au total huit cent soixante cas actifs
ont été recensés dans l'état du victoria
dans la situation est vraiment la plus
inquiétante si l'état le plus touché par
la pandémie
ce mercredi pour le troisième jour
consécutif plus de 100 personnes ont été
testées positives au colis de 19 alors
que plus d'un million de tests ont été
menés depuis le début de l'année et près
de 30000 rien que pour la journée de
mardi à l'australie a enregistré près de
9000 cas de qourna virus depuis le début
de la pandémie
mathieu merci beaucoup pour tout ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes en
fera ni merci